cal cuatro getting the ball for
cleveland and
he's working on three days rest he
started the first game of doubleheader
wednesday against the tigers that'll
bring up the center fielder miles strong
the pitch
and it's swung on lifted in the air to
fairly deep right ramirez drifting back
onto the warning track and he made the
catch
and it was not routine
harold ramirez just kept drifting and
that ball kept carrying and he almost
didn't get back far enough and just
reached out at the last moment and
snagged it
two down that'll bring up julie guriel
gauriel right-handed hitting first
baseman
no score two down the pitch a swing and
a drive pretty well hit to right center
zimmer over makes the catch
and a one two three inning for cal
cointreau and also an inning in which he
didn't have to use many pitches
astros not able to score the indians
coming to bat and the astros will send
zach reinke to the mound today and
grinky trying to become the fourth
nine-game winner in the american league
no decision in his last start two out in
a man at first for designated hitter
fran milo reyes reyes hitting 268 325 on
base percentage 11 homers
there goes rosario the 2-2 swing and a
miss got him on a breaking ball and the
ending is over so reyes down on strikes
frankie works around an infield hit and
after an inning of play astros nothing
indians here's chas mccormick
now the payoff
swing and a miss struck him out with a
good slider cuantro gets his first
strikeout mccormick the second out in
the second no score astros and cleveland
bottom of the second inning bobby
bradley left-handed hitting first
baseman stands in against greinke
bradley hitting 244 319 on base
percentage eight homer 17
runs batted in 1-2
swing and a miss another change-up gets
bradley
that one darting straight down and
that's back-to-back strikeouts for
grinky here's harold ramirez
the kick in the 2-2
swing and a miss actually a foul tip
into the glove of castro according to
vic carapaza either way that's grinky's
third straight strikeout as he gets
harold ramirez two away midfielder
taylor jones will open it up
houston and cleveland scoreless here in
the third
cuantro's next pitch
and he got him looking strike three
called on a sinker second strikeout for
cuantro jones out number one
now the number nine hitter robel garcia
d.h today switch hitter batting
left-handed no score third ending the
pitch
inside corner
good sinker locked him up
top of the order jose altuve grounded
out his first time
cuantro's pitch swung and rolled toward
third over the bag fair diving stop by
clement up throwing he got up
a lot of play
ernie clement behind the bag at third
diving backhanded stop still get up
quick enough to get of all people jose
altuve
that's about as good a play as you'll
ever see a third baseman make
no score tribe and astros in the middle
of the third
long and tall left-handed batter here
bradley zimmer
here's the one-two
and got him looking strike three zimmer
down on strikes the fastball caught him
looking there and there's one away
here's ernie clement who made that great
play down the third baseline to get out
two beta in the
top of the third ernie clement made a
great defensive play on altuve there's
strike three called
and greggy now with five strikeouts
through the first nine batters there's
two away these are hernandez the leadoff
hitter here's the 3-2 change-up guy
strike three as hernandez just watched
it go by and it's
three strikeouts in the inning for
grinke has six in the ball game we'll go
to the fourth in cleveland no score with
the astros in india
so here's mccormick
struck out first time up
here's the pitch and it's a shot up the
middle that's a base hit around third
base is straw he's gonna score
and it's one-nothing astros on the
bullet by mccormick his 30th rbi
and now abraham toro will step in toro
bounced to second his first time up
now quantrill trying to limit damage
here's his pitch
swung on and it's sky to left fairly
deep back on it is rosario makes the
catch just shy of the warning track
to retire the side but the astros strike
first on the rbi base hit by mccormick
we head to the bottom of the fourth it
is houston one to try nothing reya
struck out his last time up grinky's
been sharp just an infield single here's
the pitch
slow curve got him strike three grinky
gets his man his seventh strikeout
of the ball game and another one two
three inning he's retired 11 in a row
now
and we'll go to the fifth inning the
astros up one nothing
so two down julie guriel steps in the
2-1
swung on line drive to left rosario
there makes the catch in a crouch in
left field and the side is retired
the threat goes by the boards as the
astros strand a pair and we'll head to
the bottom of the fifth houston one the
tribe nothing
and now it's second and third with one
out for bradley zimmer
here's the 1-0
swung on a slow roller is hit up the
first baseline cranky's on it he will
tag zimmer for the out scoring from
third to tie the game is bradley
clement struck out looking in the third
pitch on the way and clement drives this
one out to right center to his right
mccormick he gets there and makes the
catch to retire the side
but cleveland picks up a run rbi ground
out by zimmer
and after five innings astros won
chaz mccormick at the plate
the 2-2
and mccormick drives this one to right
deep it sends back ramirez at the wall
looking up see you later
two-run home run for chas mccormick and
the astros are back on top three to one
mccormick's tenth of the year
here's eddie rosario has lined out
grounded out
indians batting sixth inning base is
empty two down
now the one-two pitch to eddie rosario
swung on hit pretty well to right back
is mccormick on the track at the wall he
leaps it's gone
andy rosario
with just his second home run in this
park this year
number seven overall
and the indians now trail it
by a score of three to two
reyes has struck out twice today
the 2-2 swing and a miss got him on and
off speed pitch
and grinky ties his season high with his
eighth strikeout
indians get a run closer on eddie
rosario's homer and through six innings
astros three indians two carlos correa
the hitter with two outs two on how do
you get this guy up here it comes
check swing straight free call you fool
him with a slider that's how you do it
brian shaw takes care of correa and it's
stretch time at the corner of carnegie
in ontario
and here comes bradley zimmer it seems
like every big moment
last two or three days zimmer has come
to the plate
castro flashes the signs here's the
pitch
change up grounded to the right side
gauriel's got it two steps away from the
bag he'll step on it and that's out
number three so the one out double is
stranded at third base and will go to
the eighth now in cleveland the astros
still leading three to two
here's abraham toro all for three switch
hitter banning left-handed here's the
0-1
swung on grounded to first diving
backhanded stop bradley gets up fires
wide to second somehow rosario caught it
kept his foot on the bag
throws to the third base side of second
well done
first on the dive by bradley and then
the catch by rosario
to force out the lead runner castro
top of the order and cesar hernandez
the wind and pitch
swung on hit high and deep to right
mccormick's back track wall we are tied
cesar hernandez with a towering solo
homer to right
is 14th
one shy of a career best
and the indians are back at even three
to three
top of the order now jose altuve one for
four with a
ground ball in single hole tough play
amid rosario what a throw and he got him
two away
and castro will stand in he's walked
twice and singled
one one
castro grounds it right side fielded by
bradley goes to second for one on the
first by rosario not in time and then
the ball is dropped racing home now is
guerrielle the throw to the plate say
guriel coming home to make it four to
three astros roberto perez first game
since being activated from the injured
list yesterday
corner infielders are in perez squares
bunts pops it up and it's caught by
raleigh throws the second and they
double off the runner
and it's going to be oscar mercado pinch
hitting for bradley zimmer 3-2 again
swing and a miss mercado goes down on
the high fastball and that is the ball
game